Seth asks what was the hardest thing
when starting up Vayner media from
scratch Seth you know this is another
place for me to give a little bit of
insight believe it or not yes not doing
Wine Library day-to-day with my dad yes
the notion of taking the risk of being
in another family business and not
ruining the relationship with AJ
confident on both fronts the hardest
thing was actually being crippled by
options the notion that over the first
N9 months it was very difficult for me
not to think about the fact that me and
AJ had 800 other things we could have
done and did we pick the right thing I
think a lot of people who are watching
this are always crippled I get this a
ton which is why I picked this question
why I didn't pick it you know Steve pick
or we pick we get you know how did we
pick it this one this one was
collaborative this was a little more
collaborative right you tried to give me
a different question I said
no no uh I I like this one because it
allows me to give an answer to my
audience that I see a lot of you
struggling with it's been asked of me a
ton on email Twitter and other places
which is at some point you've got to put
your big boy pants on and say I've made
this decision and you move on the
buyer's regret or remorse or like did I
do the right thing or crippled by
options is something so many of you are
struggling with and I struggle with it
as well especially with all the
opportunities that I've been able to be
given I'm so fortunate that I'm
struggling with like should I do a
national TV show should I should I
extend the fund by 10 times and do a
quar billion dollar fund should I quad
druple down on Vin or you know I'm
crippled I'm crippled by options which
is a blessing and a half and so the
hardest thing was in 2009 was like is
this the right thing don't forget Vayner
started in 09 May of 09 Misha was born
in May of 09 and crushit came out in
October of' 09 so there was all those
other things going on I was I the
struggle the hardest thing was not
starting the business it was second
guessing was was it the right use of my
time and AJ's time and upside and
talents at the time
hey